[Music]
Samuel lives here and today I'm joined
by dr. Dez Dez welcome to the show yeah
thank you thanks Sam yeah
so what are you I know you're a doctor
quite a large practice yes Ryan why did
you decide to get into property so it
was buck into late 2017 I saw your
YouTube videos and I read your book and
I was finding write in late 2017 I was
investing in stocks and shares and so I
thought were safe investments and I
wasn't getting my return on investment
so I was investing cash in things that I
was taught to believe were safe and when
I when I read your book I realized there
was another way of investing my cash a
big motivation for me was my children
because I've got four children and so
what oldest child is eight and we've got
baby who's one and so the ranges in
between I really wanted to start off a
legacy for my children yeah so
financially I'm doing quite well and
through my through my career but what
why need to leave behind is is a
portfolio and that's what I felt would
be appropriate to do and I'll see
property is a really good investment
vehicle but I needed to do that with
some training and some support I
remember when we had our one-on-one yeah
I remember when you just couldn't stand
the idea of having mortgages correct yes
yeah I get we're gonna have to agree to
disagree to some songs but I get I kind
of get that yeah tell us kind of what
happened because I was saying you want
to leverage your money is big as much as
you possibly can to get high return and
you're like oh because in your mind
you're thinking I don't want to leave
debt to my children or I don't wanna you
didn't want to retire with loads of
mortgages did you so what's your what
are you doing is your strategy now sure
so yeah the discussion really was about
and you were suggested that interest
only and most I'm always have an
interest only and I couldn't get my head
around that because I wanted my debts
paid
I was leaving as a legacy I didn't want
to hand over debt that was the mentality
I had and then I thought about it I
toyed with the idea of interest only and
I actually started sitting and chatting
with some mortgage brokers
and when I did the return on investment
sheets I looked at the difference
between repayment an interest only
there's a few hundred pound month the
difference and in my strategy I wasn't
looking for monthly cash flow is the
biggest factor the extra 100 pound a
month 150 pound a month would have made
a major difference to my and go what
would make a difference is having an
unencumbered portfolio sure I get that
because your because everyone's in
property for a different reason
property is a vehicle yeah so why did
you decide you said you would look at
stocks and shares beforehand yes what
was it about property that made you
think it was a lot it was a lot better
because now you've got property now
correct oh yeah you've got tenants and
you've been on the academy now for what
about five months a lot of time so so
why did you choose property because as
someone who's got a large you know firm
should we call it you've got money you
can't invest him you must have thought
long and hard about and you were
definitely a thinker
oh yes the spreadsheet what strategies
did you look at and what was it about
property that made you decide to go down
that route so initially looking back
that after joined your camera reading
books but the Robert Robert Kiyosaki
book the cash flow books and I actually
learned that I was a quite a passive
investor
I thought by investing giving to stock
brokers or given to fund managers that I
was being invested technically I was but
I was being a very amateur stroke
informal investor yeah although actually
with property I know exactly where my
money's going I know it's a long-term
asset and what once I read your book I
saw that actually in the money I could
put in and leverage it with the mortgage
and the money I was putting into stocks
and shares there's no leave original
option shares at all thinking about if
you put X number of pounds in stocks and
shares you get X number of pounds worth
of stocks and shares and that's it
there's no leverage
capacity there yeah and in fact it's
funny you say you read the book because
the strategy that you've gone on to do
certainly up until now has been very
much around by low rent high HMOs yeah
you've got how you've out HMO just
completed in Middlesbrough that's right
you're on the 28th that's September so
that was a that was a property that I
found
myself after doing your DfE training and
it's funny because you're such a passive
person you wait I mean when we first
bought you I'd already get involved I
don't have to do anything I'm a doctor
and I want to focus on this and I've
really you really want to be passive and
I pleaded with you didn't know I said
look even if you just have to drive up
to the area once because you don't want
people to dare to pull the wool over
your eyes trick you don't want sources
because there's a lot of bad property
sources out there yeah it's a package up
a deal that looks great on paper yeah
but then you buy it and it's terrible so
I said just go down once you came on the
deal finding extravaganza I don't think
did you even go to a crash course no I'd
join the Academy first and the very
first course I did was the DfE so you
just fast-tracked right to the very top
there no mess in at all because you
value your time so much right
not that the crash course is is not
extremely valuable but you wanted to go
right on the ditch going straight for it
yeah so so what happened in
Middlesbrough then when you went to
Middlesbrough so the first property I
went to be offs I've used several
properties on Rightmove now I found one
that was marketed as a 6 bed it was a
fully licensed HMO I think I went there
around the Easter time I when I went
there to see the property I measured up
the rooms and two of the rooms didn't
stack up and I was the hill with your
stage and holding the tape measure and
said you sure this is this has not been
let out six Bergen said yeah this has
been let out for as a 6 bed for a good
few years so what it doesn't stack up
now because there's only four rooms I
can realistically look yeah but by that
time I had made some contacts with the
council solid met it made some contest
with Steve Benson and I was ringing him
and saying but I've got this property
I'm not sure whether it was stock do you
mind if I come around and measure it so
bother and I was already making informal
networks but on that day I've got there
I couldn't make an offer on the property
because it just didn't work stuck on the
spreadsheet so I'm relieved it looked
great it said it was an up and running 6
bed hate you know yes and everything but
then you went and you were a bit wiser
yes because of the training correct
because it then it was all down to the
room sizes and yeah if I didn't know any
differently I would have bought it and I
would have bought it at a very inflated
and you know only we bought it in a very
inflated price with the new licensing
rules you wouldn't have got a license on
it yeah and you'd have actually been a
bit stuffed yes old a bit unscrewed yeah
yeah so which is important to get trains
yeah and also to sometimes go yourself
because right lose packaged
hmm and it's just a stage it's just -
absolute nonsense so so what are the
minimum squared for it for a room or
even me now it's seven point five square
meters
I know 870 square feet squared feet okay
yeah but you knew on the day at least
you or even not necessarily having all
the knowledge in your head but knowing
where it is yeah having the team to be
able to go and support so how did you
feel that when that didn't work did you
thought it was a real wasted trip or I
built up some rapport with the agent
whilst I was there because I was I was
bouncing it off him so you sure this is
HMO does the landlord know that this
doesn't stack up there's HMO going
forward I mean it's not legit right it
doesn't work yeah and I'm sort of built
in rapport with and because he
recommended that property as well he
says really good property and because of
that he said well I know you've come a
long way and I said well I've come a
long way just for this property have you
got anything outs on and he said yeah
look I'm looking to squeeze I've got
this other property and that was a five
bed it was fully lit and it's fully
licensed HMO and uh first I'm telling
you now actually made an offer there and
then said I'm gonna make an offer on the
price I'm gonna go for the asking price
but I want to come back in two weeks and
I want to meet the owner I want to go
around the property with the owner would
you take measure as well exactly take
measure everything and when outs with
the owner I was there for about an hour
an hour and a half with him just
reviewing his property yeah I asked him
everything about what the letting
history was how big the rooms are what
renovations he's done whether he's had
any property problems letting it out and
I learned from my first experience
actually go straight to the owner even
with the agent there it's really
valuable because the agents will often
just say a lot of rubbish but the owner
knows the property better than anyone
yeah and then in this chat that I've
bought it off he's got things for about
fourteen properties Roger or HMOs so why
was he selling them so he was selling to
release his equity now move on to bigger
projects sure and he's that properties
out of five
yeah letting history without fail so why
don't you tell us the figures then
because you've now got it is it renting
out yes oh I bought it with with tenants
I'll make sure I have the tenancy
agreements going into an August 2019
you've got guaranteed rent of like a
year a year basically yes correct yeah
okay
and
right in getting okay so the rent is one
seven one one per month so 1711
okay so one thousand seven hundred
eleven pounds per month that's not bad
how much do you buy the property for 135
thousand fully furnished and or Spektor
okay 135 grand and is it is it
definitely worth that you paid a good
price for it yeah it got valued up at
that it's I did the mats as well the
worked out about 27 grand a room over
the five rooms that was with the
furniture with the fire alarm with
certain tenants yeah I knew had been
licensed I'm I spoke to Steve Williams
and again about the property and he was
the one that licensed it first on round
great and the return on investment if
you works that out yeah so I've added
I've added everything clean attacks and
the legals and the renovation work
there's a light bit of reverb so a deep
clean and some painting decoration that
need to do in the tenancy of all period
on a repayment mortgage it's about 22%
yeah and on interest only pay interest
only mortgages 29% one gram for the
twenty two percent return on investment
although you say 22 percent it's
actually 29 percent but you're just
choosing with the 8 percent profit to
put that towards paying off the mortgage
it's correct but the fact that you just
bought a property that's given more than
20% return on investments pretty cool
yeah how do you feel with the with the
result of what you're doing I feel
really good for the results actually
yeah I'm really I'm really happy with
what I've got and the fact that are
sourced it myself with your training
yeah is really give me some confidence
to source all the properties in myself
and I'm becoming less passive I thought
I would be a passive investors yeah hey
seesaw Cynthia I just bring me the yeah
bring me the goods and more interested
in it why is that there and how does it
work juggling you've got a very you know
what do we say a high-pressure job I
guess you could say running running
running the business that you run how
does it work working so many hours
high-pressure business I mean I know you
love it and I know it sure yeah doing
that I I get down in there how does it
work
running that alongside building a
property portfolio especially yourself
it's not like you're just paying someone
to find your properties your hands on
how does that how do you juggle that
enhance it
there's actually quite a lot of time
free that was that was being used in
things like watching TV yeah some box
sets that'll watching and it sounds like
sacrifice but it isn't cuz actually
enjoyed looking on Rightmove and
tracking things down and quickly sifting
out actually that's no good and that
sort of skill is quite rewarding because
yeah that is something I would not have
been able to do eight months ago nine
months ago I would have thought all
these properties looked great
yeah yeah so it's a bit the game really
and then what I've got annually if I go
down and it takes him about three three
and a half hours to go down and view
property and I engage with the estate
agents have a chat with them and quiz
them so I actually quite like the
interaction with them so it's more it's
it's almost like you just see it as a
games again instead of watching box sets
or whatever you would normally doing
you're just seeing that as your
entertainment yeah yeah at the same time
I'm building a legacy for your family
yeah what do you wanting to achieve then
long term what's your because you most
people when I speak to them especially
on the academy that I'm like what's your
plan right I've got a three-month plan
in the next three months I want to
replace my income you know you were
really different you said Roy I think it
was a 20 year plan or yeah I had the
spreadsheet on my arm yeah said color
coded and everything yes like a 20 year
or 30 year plan something crazy when I'm
67 I had my children going across the
top how old they are now when they'll be
18 yeah I had it all funded and it
wasn't a short term plan you said I'm
not interested in getting quick cash
flow I'm one in a long term I want to
build wealth okay and create a legacy
what why is that then it's it's what you
can leave behind really I'm 35 now so
the mortgage is 25 28 year mortgage so
usually 25 year mortgage they'll take me
to 60 of luck so I've got four children
and all these milestones I need to be
factoring in somewhere clearly I've got
my own pension plan as well but again
with with what other things I learnt
through reading through this book there
are other ways for my children to have a
financial future that isn't isn't
medicine it isn't an academic it doesn't
always have to be an academic career
it doesn't have to be anything it can be
just a skill set that they enjoy really
and I've learned a lot about the
education system and how people are
educated into trying going into an
academic job and the only way to be
successful is go do this path and do
this path and do that path and with all
children I thought well there's got to
be something else
yeah also what does your what does your
wife think of what you're doing
interesting so my wife is aware of what
I'm doing obviously because you know now
yeah definitely definitely she's very
supportive yeah we happen to work in the
same partnership together as well so we
work together in business already
and there's partners at the practice but
on this on the investments and assets
that last my game yeah yeah I enjoy that
side of things what advice would you
give to somebody because how long have
you been a doctor I got I did med school
for 2001 to 2006 that's where I finished
my medical training so good sort of 12
years you've been actually practicing as
a doctor yes yeah as a foundation doctor
than being a GP 11 firstly why did it
take you so long as you think - I know I
know you've still young you're only 35
but why did it take you what why do you
think it took you up until now to get
into this I was generate I was working
and I was gentle I was pretty working on
my own career and I think over the last
year I've got to a point in my career
where I'm really happy with where I'm
with North Korea yeah and I can see a
long-term future in my career because
I'm the partner at the practice and I
can see the next 2530 years there I know
that set out and I'm going to stay there
long I'm not planning to move anywhere
with that sort of thing so with that
long security plan that I've got there
with my career and my income I now have
got a long investment plan prior to that
I was moving jobs I was still in
training and I wasn't quite sure which
practice I was gonna stay in there was
all that uncertainty really so with that
stability comes the investment stability
so your focus was to get
practice set up successfully outside and
when you thought right I've done that
now and that's going great because it's
interesting because a lot of people go
into property because things aren't
going great my job is not working or I
hate my job or I'm not making enough
money and they go into property but for
you it was a case of great I'm making
loads of money I've arrived I love doing
what I'm doing now I'm gonna go into
property which is which is backward to a
lot of people what was she would you say
to someone watching this who was also
successful love their job was making
good money
and was now thinking should I go into
property what advice would you give to
those people I'd advise firstly to read
your book and certainly watch your
videos and at least come on your crash
course yeah I've been on the bicycles
now have you I've been on one day the
crash got the other half to do you can
still vouch for it yeah definitely and I
just open your mind and my advice is
don't be afraid of getting investing in
your education as the Academy is an
investment in my education and when
people go to university they're quite
happy to invest in their education to go
to university or go to an apprenticeship
program the Academy is no different it's
an investment in education yeah
and how have you found the first half or
first almost half of the of the Academy
so far fantastic brilliant already can't
fault it really and the extra training
dates that I put in just just here and
there is is the valley is amazing and
it's the training as well that you get
it's not just about property training so
the phrase I'm called today and we're
learning about marketing we're learning
about structuring and we're learning
about systemising last transferable to
all I'm going to transfer that back to
my business
brilliant get back so there's lots of
value if you look at the details that
are there yeah brilliant well thanks so
much people on the show thank you
working with you and letting you go soon
thank you yes thanks thank you so much
for watching the video that is the
reason why I'm doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success units you can do that right
here but what I'd really suggest is why
don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course comment
on my guest completely free and I'll
personally be there
for two days to help you get started you
can see what happens right here what
you'll notice is all of these stories
they all start at the crash course so
come along my guests can't wait to see
you there peace out